(laughing)
- Play nice.
- You have a girlfriend, Ryan.
Does that not help you do makeup?
- What does that even--
- I don't know, she like, makes
you go to Sephora and shit.
- If I do I sit in the boyfriend chair.
There's usually a chair
there where I sit down.
- Well, I watch a lot of
YouTube videos about makeup,
so I might have an upper hand.
- Like, I know the difference
between eyeliner and mascara.
- Well, you'd think I know
a lot because I'm married,
but I really don't know much about makeup.
- Wait, are you married?
- [Voiceover] Prism Eyeshadow
- by E.L.F., which, a lot of YouTubers
talk about this brand.
- These are very unusual colors.
- Yeah.
- It's dispersing nicely, I don't...
(laughing)
- It looks really pretty,
but I'd like to see it in a few hours.
- That color payoff's not that high.
- Based on the Ned
Fulmer electronics test,
if it's heavy it's expensive,
then this is cheap so I'm gonna go $13?
- 13.01.
- Come on man, don't be like that.
- $45?
- I would say this is like
a good 30 bucks maybe?
- You could tell me that
this is $5 and I'd be like,
yup, that sounds right.
And you could tell me that it's $60,
I'd be like, that sucks, but sounds right.
(ding)
- [Ned] Oh!
- Pretty good!
- Bullshit.
- $10?! Oh, that makes me happy.
- I'm telling you, it's
all about the payoff.
It wasn't there.
- NARS sounds like your
burnout friend from college,
who like, had the fake ID.
- Wears a beanie for no reason
in the middle of summer.
- NARS is pretty expensive,
I feel like if you have
a whole thing of NARS
you're like, you're doing okay in life.
- This isn't skin-tone, for sure,
cause that looks like a fuckin' carrot.
- That's a good observation, Ryan.
This is not skin-tone.
- The other one had six
colors and it was $10,
this one has two colors,
that should be six divided by two,
so this is $3.33.
- I'm gonna say 45 on that one, too.
- I'm gonna say 35.
- I'm gonna go back, I'm gonna say 12.99.
- 35 bucks.
- I'm gonna go $15.
(ding)
- No! No! No!
- Why is it so expensive?
- [Ned] What?!
(growling) NARS? NARS?
- Ooh, that's cause he's
secretly a drag queen at night.
- I wish.
- I'm like, not happy to be closer.
Like, that sucks.
- [Curly] Naked! Urban Decay.
I feel like girls love Urban Decay.
They're always talking about
Urban Decay is so good.
- Urban Decay, that is an
expensive-sounding brand.
- The package is so wonderful.
- There's a color called Sidecar.
Just search your mind, what
do you think that looks like?
- This comes with a brush.
- But I know that's expensive.
- It is double-sided, which is cool.
This is like the Darth
Maul of makeup brushes.
- I feel like I'm doing a bad job.
I don't know, this is what--
- I'm positive you're doing a bad job.
(laughing)
- This is a great color,
these are beautiful.
Can I have this?
- Okay this is probably at least $45.
- 49.99.
- I'm gonna say 80 bucks.
- I'm gonna say 45.
- $55.
- I'm gonna go $80, and I'm
also keeping it because...
(ding)
- [Curly] Ooh! Damn, baby!
- That's a good deal.
- [Voiceover] Clé de Peau Beauté.
- Oh it's got SPF 23 in it.
- That's always good, two-for-one.
- This could go either way,
because I feel like this
could be like, super cheap
or it could be like dang,
there's placenta in this thing.
- What?!
- It's weird that it's makeup
because it feels like lotion.
- If this is like alcohol,
plastic bottle, always cheap.
- Oh I ruined it.
How do you not get makeup on your makeup?
- I'm gonna say that's gonna cost $45.
- It is covered in French.
- 17.99.
- $35.
- I feel like it's 20.
- If this tiny thing costs
20 bucks, that's crazy.
(ding)
- No! No! No!
- What?!
- That's the good shit right there.
- This will last you like three days!
This is foundation, you cover
your entire face with this!
Three of these is an Xbox!
- What the, why?
- So Ned's overreaction
aside, this is fucking insane.
- I'm sad.
- I feel like I've just
been let into a big secret
that I didn't want to know.
I feel like I just walked
in on my parents having sex.